now all right as it gets hotter outside
it's always important to focus on
protecting your skin just along that
sunblock definitely the american cancer
society predicts melanoma is the fifth
most frequently diagnosed form of cancer
in our state john langler looks at a new
way to catch the disease early
here in southern nevada we get lots of
sun it's hard to avoid with more than
300 sunny days a year doctors say it's
important to protect yourself and detect
when too much sun could lead to a deadly
illness
just peel and stick
i press down here
count to about 10. long before a mole
visibly changes melanomas put out
factors melanoma cells put out factors
that we can pick up and dermatologist dr
michael greenberg is picking them up
with a sticker it's looking for genetic
material in the cells that we pull off
you can see their cells in there
dermatec is a non-invasive diagnostic
test for the tweeners moles that can be
cancerous but don't necessarily spark
immediate concern this is an option this
is not the be-all and end-all this
doesn't replace by standard biopsies for
the moles that are suspicious lauren
casey had two spots tested during her
visit look at that
really nicely filled up with cells no
cutting no scar the 31 year old opted
for the non-invasive test after
undergoing a traditional biopsy in the
past i already have some scarring from
previous biopsies that i've had and to
have the opportunity to just have a
sticker versus
actually being cut was a
preferable option for me dr greenberg
repeats the process four times on each
spot collecting more cells with every
peel that's one done
the samples are sent to a lab for
evaluation results come back in about a
week the whole point of this test
is that it's over 99 accurate when a
melanoma is caught early patients have a
nearly 100 survival rate there are
things that used to keep me up at night
like hey did i miss something here this
gives me a lot more peace of mind and
confidence as a doctor and gives my
patients peace of mind and it's painless
and it's we don't leave scars on people
for lauren it's peace of mind it's
definitely different
especially when you have multiple done
at the same time it's a much easier
process to do what he just did
especially with the stickers i would
take that any day over a biopsy the
sticker test is covered by most
insurance plans even here in southern
nevada and it can be done during a
television for those of you who may live
in rural areas as well john langler live
local now